all right now tonight the plot thickens
Not only was blinking likely behind that
disinformation campaign we are now
learning thanks to foxnews.com that
Hunter and Tony blinken have a close
relationship dating back to 2015 here
with reaction Stephen Miller former
senior advisor to president Trump let's
get your overall reaction to all of this
and blinken and Morel and and all these
allegations and it seems that they all
put cinder blocks on the scales of a
presidential election not once but twice
Stephen
yes well this is one bombshell
revelation after another Sean and it
points directly at Tony blinken and
directly at Mike Morrell to Central
architects of these deep State plots to
interfere in our elections and to
falsely slander Donald Trump as an agent
of Russia now if you look at Tony
blinken one of the new Revelations that
you just mentioned Sean is the extent
and coziness of his relationship with
Hunter Biden to the point where he and
Hunter well well Lincoln was the deputy
secretary of state we're having secret
email exchanges using Tony blanken's
private email sound familiar with Hunter
then forwarding those exchanges to his
business partners while Hunter is
ranking in Ukrainian cash so what are
these two meeting about what are Hunter
and Tony blinken talking about with each
other while Hunter is making all this
money and then you have years later Tony
blinken apparently being the person who
set in motion the chain of events to
create the letter that we just heard all
that sound from We're 51 intelligence
operatives falsely attempted to
discredit the laptop that we all know is
completely real so again all arrows
point at Tony blinken this man has to be
deposed he has to be held before
Congress he has to be put under oath and
what we have here Sean is a conspiracy
to interfere and obstruct the American
election and if we can put someone in
jail for a meme you can certainly pursue
criminal charges in this case there
should be criminal charges certainly an
investigation a conspiracy to basically
throw an election to one candidate
anyway Stephen Miller thank you
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else